اهلا بكم من جديد ركود مؤكد يتجه نحوه
الاقتصاد العالمي مع بدايه العام 2023 بعد
فتره كبيره من التعقيد نتيجه المؤشرات غير
المسبوقه التي سجلتها معدلات التضخم
العالميه تقرير عن نشرته وكاله بلومبرج
اكد ان الاقتصاد العالميه يتجه نحو اسوا
ازمه ركود في العالم والتي كان سببها
تكاليف الاقتراب المرتفعات التي تهدف
لمعالجه التضخم وهنا حذرت كريستالينا
جورجيفا رئيسه صندوق النقد الدولي من ان
الثلث الاقتصاد العالمي سيواجهه ركودا هذا
العام في اشاره الى نصف دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي كما اشارت الى سيناري واكثر
خطوره وهو الركود التضخميه وفي هذه الحال
حال هذا التضخم سيبقى مرتفعا لفتره طويله
للغايه مع ركود اعمق واسوء حتى العام 2014
وفقا للعديد من الخبراء الاقتصاديين
فالسبب الرئيس لازمه الركود هو
ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه وارتفاع وتيره التضخم
وزياده اسعار الفائده وتراجع الاقتصاد
العالمي التي تعتبر من بين اهم اسباب
الركود المتوقعه
[موسيقى]
الركود الاقتصادي المتوقع في 2023 موضوع
مناقشه مع ضيفيه من الرياض ومن باريس من
الرياضه الاستاذ محمد العنجري الكاتب
الاقتصادي اهلا بك معنا ومن باريس الدكتور
دانيال ملحم الباحث الاقتصادي مرحبا بك
معنا دكتور استاذ محمد عن قريب في الرياض
ابدا معك يعني مع هذه التحذيرات
المتشائمه في 2023 الركود قادم بدايه يعني
نسمع الكثير من المصطلحات وهناك من يبالغ
يعني
اسوء الاقتصادي هناك نسمع مصطلحات عن
الركود عن الكساد عن الانكماش ما الفرق
بين كل هذه المصطلحات الاقتصاديه وهل هي
حتميه في 2023
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لكم للساده
المشاهدين هو لا يمكن القول ان هناك شيء
حتمي هي مجرد اشارات يعني يضعها امامه
المحلل الاقتصادي اجمالا او المؤسسه
الاقتصاديه
الركود طبعا هو تباطؤ في النمو الاقتصادي
واعاده ما يقاس بنتيجه لربعين متتاليين
حتى يقال ان هناك ركود وهناك ايضا تعريفات
يعني مثلا ظهرت مؤخرا مثلا في امريكا يقول
لك انه ركود عميق او انه ركود يعني همم
لنقل انه بسيط هم ينظرون الى مثلا معدلات
البطاله عندما ترتفع معدلات البطاله بشكل
كبير سيرون انه ركود عميق اما الكاسات فهو
حال اقتصاديه يعني اشبه بالدمار الاقتصاد
لانها تحول يعني الكثير من الشركات الى
الافلاس وايضا ترتفع فيها نسب البطاله
بشكل همم جنوني الان ال- ال- ال- يعني
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه لماذا تحمل هذه
الضبابيه وهذا التعدد في همم المصطلحات
همم لو نظرنا الى همم ابعد قليلا منذ
بدايه الازمه الماليه عام 2008 هرب العالم
بشكل عام وخصوصا المكان الذي وقعت فيه
الاسباب الى الامام بخصي ولكبيره فترات
طويله من انخفاض سعر الفائده وعدم الدخول
في اصلاحات اقتصاديه
الحقيقيه لما عندما جاءت ازمه كورونا كان
العالم اصلا مستعد الى تراجع في الاقتصاد
فجاءت ازمه كورونا ويعني وانا اعتبر ان هي
الكارثه الكبرى لماذا لانها بالاضافه الى
التراجع في نمو الاقتصاد هناك اقفالات ادت
الى قطاع في سلاسل الامداد الى مديونيه
عاليه همم يعني اخذتها الدول حتى تعالج
هذه الازمه تقريبا الذخيره لذا ال- ال-
السياسه النقديه تحديدا شبه السنفذ ولذلك
اليوم جاءت الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
لتكمل همم ايضا على الاقتصاد العالمي مما
ادى الى ظهور هذه الحاله التشاؤميه نعم
الكبيره نعم طيب دكتور دانيال همم من
باريس البشريه مرت بحوالي 50 همم فتره من
الركود الاقتصادي بدايه من هلع النحاس عام
1985 وصولا الى الركود العظيم في 2008
اضافه انه فتره رائحه كورونا اعتبرت يعني
نوع من انواع الركود همم كذلك المتوقع في
2023 اي نوع من انواع الركود هل يمكن ان
يشبهه ب 2008
امبركود فتره كورونا الذي كان يتحدث عنه
الاستاذ
تحيه لك يا سيدي الكريم والمشاهدين وينعاد
على الجميع نعم اليوم هذه الفتره التي
تشبه اي فتره سابقه ولا يمكن ااا
مقارنتها بيئيه من العديد من الفترات هي
مزيج ما بين ما بين ازمه ال 2001 لان
بنتكلم ان سلوك الاسواق يشبه ازمه الالفين
2001 وشبيه ايضا بازمه 1981 ولكن هي
مختلفه كليا لماذا لانه هناك عده اعتبارات
جديده نحن نتكلم عن الازمه اليوم هو نحن
نتجه الى عالم اكثر في اكثر تعقيدا وان
نتكلم عن كومبلك سيستم او الانضمام
المعقده في الاقتصاد وبالتالي هي لا تشبه
الامور المختلفه لانه عندما نرى الى الفت
لعام 1981 كانت المديونيه العامه للعالم
هي توازن 100% من الناتج القومي اليوم
هناك المديونيه 350%
اكثر في اكثر من 2008 كان هناك عمليا تضخم
منخفض جدا وبالتالي عندما دخلنا في ازمه
اقتصاديه تدخلت سياسات النقديه وحفظت
الاقتصاد اليوم هو ي 7% في الولايات
المتحده 10%
لو سمحت
الفيدرالي الامريكي يعني طوال تسعه اشهر
الماضيه وهو يرفع سعر الفائده بهدف
التقليل من التضخم اخر مؤشرات يعني التضخم
منخفض بشكل قليل جدا لماذا هذا الارتفاع
الجنوني في التضخم يعني ليس فقط في امريكا
بل بالعالم هل بسبب الحرب الاوكرانيه ام
ثم عوامل اخرى
نعم في الولاده هناك صحيحه ان هناك تضخم
مشابه في كافه الدول العالم باوروبا او في
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا ولكن هناك
مختلف كليا هل تضخم في الولايات المتحده
عن فائض في الطلب وهذا ناتج عمليا على
التحفيز الكبير في القدره الشرائيه انها
عن حزمت بين في مارس عفوا الناس ال 21
اضافه لذلك الى التسهيلات وتاخر في دلال
الامريكي عن التدخل ادى الى ما حدث اليوم
وزاد في الطلب الكره او التضخم الاساسي
يرتفع بشكل كبير لذلك قد تضخم في الولايات
المتحده هو الناتج عن فائض في الطلبه
الداخلي في اوروبا من التضخم ناتج عن ازمه
الطاقه يعني عمليا الازمه اللي هو
الجرانيت ارتفاع في تكاليف الانتاج
وبالتالي عمليا هناك الامور مختلفه
كليا في بريطانيا كان بدا الامر كما في
الولايات المتحده وانتهى كما حدث في
اوروبا وبالتالي امازيج بين الاثنين استاذ
محمد العنجري همم البنوك الخليجيه
المركزيه يعني هي مرتبطه الامريكي عندما
يرفع الفائده فهي كذلك ترفع نسبه الفائده
العملات كذلك مرتبطه بالدولار هل الركود
الذي يحذر منه صندوق النقد الدولي في 2023
همم اذا ما حصل يعني هل ستتاثر الدول
العربيه كذلك بنفس النسبه او همم بمعنى ان
سيكون هذا الركود عالميا ويشملن ايضا يشمل
الخليج والشرق الاوسط كذالك
نحن جزء من العالم وبالتالي هناك بعض
التاثيرات التي ستحدث لكن ما يريح دول
الخليج ان لديها وساده ماليه قويه
ومديونيات منخفضه بالاضافه الى ان اسعار
الطاقه والتي تمثل يعني جزء مهم جدا دائما
للتنميه ما زالت في مستويات مريحه جدا
ولذلك انا اعتقد ان التاثير همم على دول
الخليج سيكون اقل نعم بكثير همم من اي همم
منطقه جغرافيه اخرى حتى في عالمنا العرب
يعني هناك دول عربيه اعتقد انها تتاثر همم
بالضبط
يعني اليوم نلاحظ مثلا مصر كيف يتراجع
فيها سعر الجنيه بالاضافه الى
احتياجها الى ان ترفع من مخزوناتها من
المواد الغذائيه هي اكبر دوله عربيه هناك
ايضا دول اخرى في المغرب العربي قد تتاثر
صحيح لذلك يعني لا يمكن اليوم اعتبار ان
كل الدول العربيه ستتاثر بنفس النسب لكن
بالنسبه للدول الخليج ستبقى في وضع يعني
افضل خصا ان السياساتها الماليه ايضا
تحفيزيه في الاقتصاد وحتى يعني الارقام
التي اصدرها همم صندوق النقد وحتى توقعات
الحكومات نفسها مع اعلان الميزات نعملها
كانت تشير الى همم معدلات نمو بحدود يعني
اثنين ونصف الى ثلاثه ونصف بالمئه
بالمتوسط وهذا جيد في عام يعني قد يشهد
اضطرابات على مستوى العالم وهو ال- ال-
الجانب الاخطر في تاثيرات العقود الركود
التضخمي الذي يعني يحذر من نعم دكتور
دانيال ااه الركود المقبل اذا ااه
يفهمه الانسان ربما انه سيكون هناك ارتفاع
في اسعار السلع عدم القدره على همم تلبيه
الحاجيات التي كنا نستطيع ان ندفع ثمنها
همم سابقا همم ربما فقدان للكثير من
الوظائف اا على مستوى المواطن كيف يمكن
التحضر لهذا الركود في 2023 ماذا علينا ان
نفعل كمواطنين كافراد كي نتحضر لمواجهه
هذا الركود ولا يؤثر علينا بشكل كبير
سيدي الجميع يتكلم عن ركود ولكن انا اريد
ان اقول كما قال سامولسن ابو الاقتصاد
الحديث ان هناك كل الاقتصاديين توقع 11
مره الركود ولكن لم يحدث الاربعه مرات
خلال 100 سنه الاخيره وبالتالي اليوم نعم
الكل يتوقع انا ارى عمليا اذا اخذنا سيدي
فقط نقطتين او اذا اخذنا على قطعه الركود
في الولايات المتحده هو ليس حتمي اليوم
المعطيات الاقتصاديه القويه جدا وهناك
احتمال كبير ان تتجنب
الحلقه ولكن انا ساخذ تفاؤلك على محمل
الجد نتمنى ان لا يحصل الركود دكتور
دانيال من تاريخ شكرا جزيلا لك هو الاستاذ
محمد العنجري من الرياض شكرا جزيلا لك
مشاهدينا شكرا لكم على المشاهده الى
اللقاء